which we were all hoping was maybe gonna
be the Last Guardian I realized oh we
hadn't seen it yet yeah who's Jenna baby
wasn't at war
we're gonna have to see uncharted 4 and
so we did a thief's end is the title it
was revealed but it's basically just to
look at Nathan Drake sexy face trailer
yeah cuz they showed that logo before
and that I've shown like I guess it's
running an engine and it looks pretty
great but like this isn't gameplay or
anything so I don't know how can hurry
up so many shows if you're gonna finish
the show with this I don't know like
walks into the jungle I was like yes is
we're gonna see him walk through then
the plants are gonna look beautiful done
but what do you think of the character
model of Nathan Drake I don't know if
you guys have played much Uncharted it
looks a little different I mean it still
recognizably him but I feel like I don't
know this little they mess with him a
little bit for the ps4 you know at the
end of day he is still recognizable and
it's amazingly detailed yeah i guess
this looks in engine but may not be
representative always gonna look like
when there's other stuff going on right
I think what they've done is they've
because their work I guess with his face
in the especially in two and three was
quite I don't know there to like make it
more extreme it was rather cartoonish to
make it look the way he is and because
this looks so I don't know because
there's so much more detail you can't
really do that without making somebody
look like like they're not really human
it looks like they've just softened the
edges I guess I was really hoping just
put out a PSP with ribbon on it yeah
this bit is like man they did the recap
at the very end then they went down all
the games in one trailer and every was
here like maybe maybe do a bit of pretty
is gonna show like one frame with The
Last Guardian and
they were just like no I didn't not
giving you nothing no Last Guardian but
a lot of games a lot of Sony first part
exclusives a lot of third-party games
showing up in Sony's press conference
that did not show anywhere else today
most notably in the Microsoft press
conference so let's let's wrap it up